hey Kerry we're doing it how you doing
thank you I was overhearing a
conversation about a bunch of joints at
the inauguration you're in charge of
research opposed for you to figure if
anybody knows it's true or not it's you
is there gonna be a bunch of wheat that
that sounds amazing there's a lot of
stuff going on with the inauguration I'm
at okay that's true you imagine I feel
like the most important place to start
with nickelback bullet what does
Nickelback have anything to do with the
inauguration so there was this tweet
going around people were just like
reposting this image on Facebook and
Twitter that's Donald Trump says we did
it we secure Nickelback for the
inauguration very pleased a great
American band it sounds like a match
that's Trump
yes how Trump tweets it's his handle
it's verified we got timestamp at Target
so they're playing the inauguration
they're actually not it's fake
no he lost them no it's me no it's not
like they backed out at the last minute
how can it be fake it's very Trumpy it's
a tweet so the things this is just an
image it's not a link there's like no
proof you can't click through I can't on
the Internet no cuz you can fake him I
know mine are real I do feel for them so
there you go yeah I guess so
so here's what he actually tweeted at
that same time we did it thank you to
all my great supporters we just
officially won the election despite all
of the distorted in that accurate media
so look the time stamp and the date are
the exact same oh so we didn't get
Nickelback oh is it because Nickelback
was too busy let's look at their tour
schedule hmm they only have three
shooters 2017 maybe they just haven't
booked them yet I just really wish they
were playing the inauguration Oh
okay so what else you got so after mile
Street's Golden Globe speech the New
York Times called him to get his
thoughts on it and why not well that's
all I'm actually calling about what's a
what's a better source than going
directly to him on the trunk phone but
then he ended up saying this we are
going to have an unbelievable perhaps
record-setting turnout for the
inauguration and there will be plenty of
movie in entertainment stars all the
dress shops are sold out in Washington
it's hard to find a great dress for the
inauguration poor Trumpy wants a dress
you can't have him get his own dress
that's terrible I know
they're all they're all sold out I mean
the thing is New York Times didn't
fact-check what he said why not we could
fact check what he says let's forget it
yeah we could call a dress shop hi I'm
Keith I was wondering if y'all have any
dresses you know what I'm shopping for
the inauguration
I need several dresses yeah I mean it
the style does really matter I think
we're more wondering how many dresses
you have to choose from like you have a
lot of dresses I'm just gonna be honest
I'm probably not coming all right by the
Trump is wrong he said something that
wasn't true
so there's fake news there's real news
that's fake well this is real news of it
just like he lie yeah okay so no go back
stop playing there are plenty of dresses
for Trump to choose from what what about
the week tell me about the week cuz now
I'm assuming that the week can be real
either all these stories do you think so
the good news is the weed is real we're
doing it to give it our week it's real
you can get some weed if we good and be
hungry how many weeds can I have so CNN
it turns out if you read this story the
people passing out the lead are from an
organization called DC MJ which helped
pass this cannabis mine chain that's
probably what it stands for sure it's DC
mayor wanted to see Mary Jane yeah are
they gonna give these out to only chill
people are they gonna choose like the
old angry people to give it to you to
say like chill out
it does getting the weak it sounds like
anyone they are passing out four
thousand and two hundred joints asking a
variation if Trump has not said he'll
legalize need throughout the country in
the first 4 minutes and 20 seconds of
his speech then every
one should light their joints at the
same time sounds like a bunch of
potheads to me so this is true there
really will be we do they know a couple
that got news yeah you know cuz there's
gonna be all these people upset about
not having dresses and upset the
Nickelback's not there and they're gonna
need some to chill out with and Elise
are gonna have 4200 joints to choose
from it's true I think you'll probably
just get one I don't know if you got to
choose yo party to make bigger teams oh
yeah and do you think Trump will be
offered any week he knows all about weed
he talks about weed with the best weeds
I think we might need to fact check that